Können wir mit Hilfe der Tiere schon bald in
die Zukunft sehen? Elefanten, die Tsunamis weit
im Voraus spüren. Kröten, die sich retten
lange bevor die Erde bebt und Ziegen, die
einen Vulkanausbruch “voraussagen” können. Tiere
reagieren äußerst sensibel auf Umweltveränderungen
und warnen damit vor Gefahren und Bedrohungen.
Das internationale Forschungsprojekt “Icarus”
macht sich das zunutze. Dabei werden Tiere
als richtige Detektive eingesetzt und das sehr
erfolgreich. Clixoom Science & Future - hier gibt
es drei Mal pro Woche spannende Science-Videos -
abonniert den Kanal und aktiviert die Glocke.
Nur so verpasst ihr nichts… Los geht’s!
Herzlich willkommen! Dieses Video ist in
Zusammenarbeit mit Technology Review entstanden,
dem Technologiemagazin des MIT, dem Massachusetts
Institute for Technology. Und am Ende gibt es ein
Exemplar für euch kostenlos. Sie sind wirklich
überall unterwegs. In der trockensten Wüste,
im tiefsten Regenwald und auf den höchsten Bergen
überhaupt. Tiere, die die Umwelt erkunden. Und
genau das machen sich Forschungsteams weltweit
bereits heutzutage zunutze: Die amerikanische
Wetter- und Meereskundebehörde beispielsweise
nutzt Seeelefanten bereits seit einigen Jahren
als mobile Messbojen. Sensoren werden an den
Tieren befestigt und da diese bis zu 1.500 Meter
tief tauchen, kommen die Wissenschaftlerinnen
und Wissenschaftler so sehr einfach an spannende
Daten wie Salzgehalt, Strömung und Temperatur der
Meere. Der große Vorteil: Die damit verbundenen
Kosten sind deutlich niedriger als beispielsweise
der Einsatz von Tauchrobotern. Weitere Beispiele
für Tiere, die als Messstationen fungieren,
gibt es viele: Schneegeier liefern spannende
Daten aus dem Himalaja - und das aus einer Höhe
von mehr als 8000 Metern. Vor allem in Regionen,
wo wir Menschen nur schwer hingelangen oder wo
sich der Einsatz von konventionellen Messgeräten
kompliziert gestaltet, sind es Tiere,
die die Werte erheben. So unter anderem
auch auf der Lee-Seite von Gebirgen, wo oft
Wolken die Messungen per Satellit unmöglich
machen. Gemeint ist hiermit diejenige Seite
von Gebirgen, die dem Wind abgewandt ist.
Manchmal ist auch vom sogenannten “sechsten
Sinn” der Tiere die Sprache. So auch kurz vor
der Jahrhundertkatastrophe Ende des Jahres 2004,
als ein gewaltiger Tsunami im Indischen Ozean rund
230.000 Menschenleben forderte. Medienberichten
zufolge hatten sich die Tiere dieser Gegend im
Vorfeld äußerst unruhig verhalten. So hatten
sich beispielsweise die Elefanten nervös hin
und her bewegt; ihre Ohren ausgebreitet und
waren einen einen Berg hinauf gerannt. Auch
die Vögel stiegen demnach verschreckt in den
Himmel und flogen landeinwärts. In China wurde
über ein ähnliches Beispiel berichtet:
Kurz vor einem Erdbeben sollen tausende
von Kröten wild über die Straßen gehüpft sein.
Später starben dann mehr als 50.000 Menschen.
Hatten die Tiere die drohende Gefahr gewittert
oder war es etwa reiner Zufall? Klar jedenfalls
ist, dass Tiere mehrere Sinne gleichzeitig
einsetzen und somit in der Lage sind,
kleine Veränderungen sehr viel früher wahr
zu nehmen als wie Menschen. Dagegen steht die
Ahnungslosigkeit von Seismologen, die erst wenige
Sekunden vor dem Erdbeben wissen, dass es soweit
ist. Bislang kann man einfach nicht voraussagen,
wann und wo sich die Spannungen an den Erdplatten
entladen werden. Zwar gibt es beispielsweise
in Mexiko-Stadt effiziente Warnsysteme,
um die Menschen zu alarmieren, doch das ist eher
die Ausnahme. Die Herausforderung liegt darin,
dass die hochsensiblen Sensoren gut überlegt
platziert werden müssen. Ähnliche Probleme
haben Forschungsteams weltweit bei der Vorhersage
von Vulkanausbrüchen. Zwar wurden einige Prozesse
identifiziert, die einen Vulkanausbruch
ankündigen. Doch der konkrete Zeitpunkt
für den Ausbruch und auch seine Stärke –
das ist viel zu komplex, um es im Vorfeld
physikalisch zu berechnen. Auch hier sind uns
einige Tierarten - wie beispielsweise Ziegen
und Rote Waldameisen - voraus. Der deutsche
Biologe Martin Wikelski vom Max-Planck-Institut
für Ornithologie hat erforscht, dass Ziegen vor
einem Ausbruch des Vulkans Ätna außergewöhnlich
aktiv wurden. Und das mehrere Stunden, bevor
der Vulkan tatsächlich ausbrach. Schon vor
Jahren hatte sein Forschungsteam die Ziegen und
Schafe vor Ort mit Tags versehen. Und tatsächlich:
Bei den vergangenen sieben Ausbrüchen
des Ätnas hatten die Tiere bereits vier
bis sechs Stunden vor der Katastrophe das
Weite gesucht. Also zu einem Zeitpunkt,
wo noch kein anderes Messgerät angeschlagen hatte.
Auch Rote Waldameisen reagieren offensichtlich auf
ein anstehendes Erdbeben, wie Forschungsteams aus
Duisburg und Dortmund berichten. Die Fachleute
hatten über drei Jahre hinweg beobachten können,
dass die Ameisen sehr empfindlich auf Aktivitäten
unter der Erde reagierten. Durch ihre speziellen
Sinnesorgane sind die Ameisen möglicherweise in
der Lage, aufsteigende Gase und vielleicht sogar
auch elektrische Spannung wahrzunehmen. Diese
Fähigkeiten der Tiere wollen Fachleute weltweit
nutzen, um in die Zukunft zu sehen und möglich
Umweltgefahren vorauszusagen. So wie die Bergleute
etwa ab dem Jahr 1880 auch den“Harzer Roller”,
einen gelben Kanarienvogel, auch für ihre Zwecke
nutzten. Denn dieser Vogel singt sogar dann,
wenn es dunkel ist - so also auch in der Grube.
Doch das Tier ist sehr anfällig für schlechte
Luft. Es verstummt, sobald die Kohlenmonoxid-Werte
steigen und bereits nach kurzer Zeit wird der
Vogel bewusstlos. Sobald der Harzer Roller also in
seinem Käfig von der Stange kippte, war dies den
Bergleuten eine ernste Warnung vor gefährlichen
Gasen in der Grube, die sie dann schnellstmöglich
verließen. Doch anders als noch vor 140 Jahren
läuft das heute weitaus professioneller.
Möglich wird das unter anderem auch durch die
Miniaturisierung der Technik, sodass Fachleute
den Tieren immer kleinere und komplexere Tags mit
auf den Weg geben können - Computerchips also mit
Sendern und Sensoren. Ganz vorne mit dabei
das internationale Projekt namens “Icarus”,
wobei Tiere schon in naher Zukunft die ganze Erde
vermessen könnten. Icarus steht für “International
Cooperation for Animal Research Using Space“ und
wird vom Max-Planck-Institut für Ornithologie in
Radolfzell geleitet. Mit dabei unter anderem aber
auch das Deutsche Zentrum für Luft- und Raumfahrt
(DLR) und die russischen Raumfahrtbehörde
Roskosmos. Die Empfangsstation wurde im
vergangenen Jahr (2019) auf der Raumstation ISS
montiert. Tiere auf der ganzen Welt könnten in
Zukunft also mit Peilsendern und Sensoren für
Temperatur, Bewegung und Luftdruck ausgestattet
werden und so diese Daten regelmäßig und
automatisch an die ISS funken. Hier werden die
Funksignale hunderter Tags gleichzeitig in hoher
Auflösung verarbeitet und an die Bodenstationen
weitergeleitet. So wird die Datenerhebung deutlich
einfacher gemacht als es bei regionalen und
bodengebundenen Empfängern der Fall ist.
Die Fachleute können somit nicht nur die
Umweltdaten aus extrem entlegenen Regionen der
Erde gewinnen, sondern auch minutiös verfolgen,
was die Tiere gerade machen. Wann schlafen sie,
wann und so fressen sie, auf welchen Routen
bewegen sie sich und wann und warum sterben sie?!
Dazu der Wissenschaftler Martin Wikelski,
der maßgeblich am Icarus-Projekt beteiligt ist:
“So gewinnen wir nicht nur viel tiefere Einblicke,
wie Tiere auf Umweltveränderungen reagieren,
um den Artenschutz zu verbessern. Wir werden
auch auf Umweltgefahren aufmerksam, die
sonst länger unbemerkt geblieben wären.“
Ist es möglicherweise vor allem das
Schwarmverhalten der Tiere, das sie so intelligent
macht? Ist es also eine kollektive Intelligenz;
quasi eine Art Algorithmus im Verhalten der Tiere,
die ihnen das Überleben sichert? Doch wie genau
stehen dabei die Interaktion der Tiere und ihr
Verhalten in der Gruppe in Zusammenhang mit dem
sechsten Sinn? Ein erster Test im Rahmen des
Icarus-Projekts bezieht sich auf den Zug der
Amseln. Somit soll endlich eine spannende und
bislang ungeklärte Forschungsfrage geklärt werden:
Warum zieht nur die Hälfte der Amsel-Populationen
in Mitteleuropa und Nordamerika über den Winter
nach Süden und warum bleibt die andere Hälfte vor
Ort? In Stuttgart und Karlsruhe sollen Tauben
eingesetzt werden, um Daten zur Luftchemie zu
sammeln. Doch als Bioindikatoren umfasst der
Einsatzbereich der Tiere noch viel mehr. Denn
mit ihrer Hilfe könnten sogar Verbrechen
aufgeklärt werden: Beispielsweise könnte
der illegale Fischfang eingedämmt und Wilderern
das Handwerk gelegt werden. Das Problem bei der
illegalen Fischerei: Die Fischtrawler schalten
während ihrer Machenschaften die Transponder
der automatischen Identifizierungssysteme ab und
so werden die illegalen Fischer unsichtbar für
die Satellitenüberwachung. Nicht jedoch für die
Albatrosse, die noch aus 30 Kilometern Entfernung
jeden Fischtrawler aufspüren und auf leichte Beute
hoffen. Wenn die Tiere mit einem solarbetriebenen
Peilsender ausgestattet werden, verraten sie
somit über das Radarsignal des Schiffes auch die
illegalen Fischer. Die Trawler lassen ihren Radar
nämlich weiter laufen, da sie sonst nicht mehr in
der Lage sind, zu navigieren. Ein französisches
Forschungsteam konnte so mithilfe von knapp
180 Albatrossen das riesige Ausmaß der illegalen
Fischerei im südlichen Indischen Ozean offenbaren.
In einem Gebiet, das viermal so groß wie Europa
ist, registrierten die Vögel 353 Schiffe. Doch der
Abgleich mit dem vorgeschriebenen automatischen
Erkennungssystem zeigte, dass 100 davon der
offiziellen Überwachung entgehen wollten.
In Afrika zeigt ein anderes Projekt eindrucksvoll,
wie Tiere Verbrechen aufspüren können. Ganz
konkret werden hier illegale Wilderer ertappt.
Dazu Martin Wikelski: “Anfangs hatten wir die
Idee, Nashörner oder Löwen direkt zu taggen.
Anhand ihrer Bewegungsmuster können wir eindeutig
erkennen, wenn sie gejagt und geschossen werden.
Schicken wir dann die Ranger los, ist es aber
meist zu spät.“ Und genau deswegen stehen jetzt
Tiere wie Gazellen, Giraffen und Zebras im Visier
des Forschungsteams. Denn diese Fluchttiere zeigen
ganz bestimmte ZITAT “Herden-Fluchtmuster”,
wenn ihnen Wilderer zu nahe kommen. Und
genau diese Muster sind viel eindeutiger
von anderen Gefahren zu unterscheiden.
Nun erarbeiten die Wissenschaftlerinnen und
Wissenschaftler ein Alarmsystem, wobei Giraffen,
Zebras und Gazellen mit solarbetrieben
Ohrmarken-Tags ausgestattet werden.
Doch es sind nicht nur Säugetiere, die als
Frühwarnsystem fungieren könnten, sondern
auch Insekten oder kleine Vögel. Möglich wird das,
weil Sender und Sensoren dank neuer Technologien
in Zukunft noch kleiner werden. Derzeit sind die
leichtesten davon 3,8 Gramm schwer, wenn sie per
Solarkraft betrieben werden und 2,3 Gramm schwer,
wenn sie mit Batterien laufen. Derzeit sind die
kleinsten Vögel, die eine solche Last tragen
können etwa so groß wie ein 100 Gramm schwerer
Kuckuck. Doch die Pläne der Fachleute sind groß.
Dazu Martin Wikelski: “„In einem Konsortium mit
mehreren Instituten und Unternehmen arbeiten wir
da­ran, unter ein Gramm zu kommen. Dann können wir
auch kleinere Vögel und sogar Insekten besendern,
die uns noch viel mehr über die Zusammenhänge in
der Natur verraten.“ Langfristig gesehen soll so
ein Sensorsystem entstehen, das die gesamte Erde
umspannt. Möglich machen könnte das ein Netzwerk
an Satelliten, die den Tieren nachhorchen. Und das
könnte dann nicht nur uns Menschen zugute kommen,
sondern auch den Tieren selbst. Dazu Stefan Dech
vom Deutschen Zentrum für Luft- und Raumfahrt.
“Wenn wir anhand der von ihnen gelieferten Daten
Geschichten vom Schicksal gefährdeter Tierarten
erzählen können, entsteht mehr Bereitschaft,
wirklich etwas für den Umwelt- und Artenschutz zu
tun.“ Spannende Zukunftsperspektiven sind das und
noch mehr davon gibt es bei Technology
Review: Hier wird in jeder Ausgabe in
die Zukunft geschaut. In Zusammenarbeit mit der
Redaktion von Technology Review ist dieses Video
entstanden. Und exklusiv für Clixoom-Zuschauer
gibt es jetzt eine Ausgabe gratis. Klickt dafür
einfach auf diesen Link oder unten in die
Videobeschreibung. Bis dann, bleibt dran!